[Musica]
Questa sera vorrei bussare alla porta
delle vostre case chiedervi il permesso
di intrufolarmi nelle vostre vite
domestiche per raccontarvi qualcosa che
normalmente nessuno di noi associa la
propria quotidianità Specialmente se
vive in città anche se vivete in un
appartamento in un palazzo al centro di
una metropoli e anche se non ci avete
mai pensato vi assicuro che in ciascuna
delle vostre case anche se un po' in
controluce C'è un bosco una foresta o
meglio Molto spesso anche molto più di
una e tranquilli non c'è bisogno di
avere il pollice verde Anch'io sono una
frana in questo Rischio sempre di far
morire anche le piante grasse C'è un
bosco In ogni casa perché anche se da
millenni ormai siamo scesi dalle piante
il nostro rapporto con alberi e boschi
rimane tutt'oggi profondo
e indissolubile C'è un bosco in ogni
caso Innanzitutto perché siamo
circondati dal legno tavoli porte
finestre librerie pavimenti cornici
tetti oggetti di uso comune il legno È
una straordinaria materia prima
rinnovabile che se fosse stata inventata
da un essere umano questo avrebbe
meritato almeno tre premi Nobel quello
per la chimica quello per la fisica e
molto probabilmente anche quello per la
pace perché il legno la materia prima
che più ha accompagnato l'umanità in
passato e che al tempo stesso è
considerato oggi una materia prima del
futuro che potrà aiutarci veramente
tanto nella transizione ecologica Qual è
il suo segreto
Beh il suo segreto è nascosto tra le
cellule disposte in lunghe file e
contorniate da molecole molto
particolari che lo rendono al tempo
stesso rigido ed elastico flessibile e
leggero e poi il legno è pieno di
carbonio carbonio che è stato assorbito
dall'atmosfera durante la vita degli
alberi sotto forma di CO2 e che è stato
immagazzinato anche nel legno quindi nel
trave che sorregge il tetto di un'antica
cattedrale c'è nascosto il respiro dei
nostri avi carbonio che è rimasto
fissato bloccato lì da secoli e che
ancora lo rimarrà non ritornando in
atmosfera ma il tempo stesso altre
piante cresciute al posto di
quell'albero divenuto trave continuano
ad assorbire CO2 dell'atmosfera mentre
crescono quella CO2 che a causa nostra
ha raggiunto livelli così alti da
provocare il riscaldamento globale ed è
per questo motivo che alberi e boschi
insieme possono darci una mano molto
importante nella mitigazione della crisi
climatica e poi non dimentichiamoci che
il legno è anche calore quindi fonte di
energia molti non lo sanno ma oggi è la
prima materia prima rinnovabile del
nostro paese
e poi il legno nelle nostre case anche
sotto forma di melodia quando Ascoltiamo
una musica e non importa che sia Rock
jazz o classica spesso c'è di mezzo il
legno con il quale sono realizzati la
maggior parte degli strumenti musicali
ma nelle nostre case il bosco non c'è
solo sotto forma di legno il bosco nelle
nostre case è anche Nei rubinetti
immaginate di percorrere al contrario il
viaggio di una goccia d'acqua passereste
nei tubi nell'acquedotto e arrivereste
su su su fino ad una fonte che molto
probabilmente è proprio lì nel bosco
perché il bosco è anche un incredibile
filtro naturale che riesce a captare le
precipitazioni atmosferiche e a
trasformarle in acqua potabile come fa
Beh grazie al suolo il suolo forestale è
un intrico incredibile di radici Tra
l'altro microbiologicamente attivo in
cui l'acqua percola molto lentamente
arrivando nelle falde con livelli
veramente molto elevati di qualità
e poi il bosco nelle nostre case anche
nel frigorifero o nella dispensa
Immagino che anche voi come me amerete i
funghi i tartufi frutti di bosco le
castagne il miele Ebbene sì Il bosco è
anche lì è buono che è
il bosco nelle nostre case anche nelle
nostre foto ricordo quelle che scattiamo
con la nostra famiglia o i nostri amici
magari scarpinando in un bosco d'abete
ai piedi delle Dolomiti o pedalando in
una pineta di fianco al mare e il bosco
nelle nostre case è anche nelle librerie
non solo perché le librerie sono fatte
di legno e neppure perché i libri sono
fatti di carta e quindi di polpa di
legno e quindi di alberi No Il bosco è
proprio anche tra le pagine tra le righe
perché il bosco è cultura dalla selva
oscura di Dante a Cappuccetto Rosso
passando per la più straordinaria favola
italiana il cui protagonista è un
burattino di legno creato da un
falegname
e poi Qui siamo in Veneto
alzi la mano Chi di voi è astemio
pochissimi pochissimi pochissimi Vabbè
vi capisco Infatti io non l'ho alzata la
mano Ebbene sì Il bosco nelle nostre
case è anche nel vino Nel tappo
realizzato con la corteccia di una
quercia La Quercia da sughero ma anche
nel gusto Perché molti vini passano in
barrique o in botti realizzati spesso
con un'altra Quercia La Rovere e non
solo perché molto spesso proprio le viti
stesse crescono aggrappate anche a pali
di castagno Ecco io potrei andare avanti
ancora e ancora ma ora vorrei invitarvi
ad aprire le finestre delle vostre case
e a percepire il bosco anche nell'aria
nella regolazione del clima
nell'ossigeno ad immaginarlo come lo
scrigno per la maggior parte della
biodiversità che ci circonda ad
immaginarlo come luogo di benessere
psicofisico oppure anche ad osservarlo
così come pura bellezza e fonte di
ispirazione
vedete tutte queste cose che vi ho
descritto E che ho cercato nelle vostre
case hanno un nome preciso si chiamano
servizi ecosistemici e per generarli
questi servizi molto spesso non basta il
bosco e no la natura da sola talvolta
non basta serviamo anche noi o meglio
persone come noi che di mestiere il
bosco lo gestiscono se ne prendono cura
ricercatori addetti al controllo alla
conservazione ma anche proprietari
amministratori tecnici operatori
boscaioli persone che di mestiere il
bosco e lo studiano lo pianificano lo
conservano ma anche ci entrano dentro
modificando nella struttura cioè
realizzando interventi Selvi culturali
Quindi anche tagliando alberi Ebbene sì
anche tagliando alberi Anche se questa
cosa Oggi è sempre solo vista come una
cosa assolutamente negativa da
condannare da evitare Ma se il legno è
così importante nelle nostre vite Beh
allora qualche albero bisogna anche
tagliarlo così come le fonti vanno
tenute pulite il sughero va estratto i
funghi e tartufi vanno raccolti una
strada un sentiero vanno costantemente
manutenuti
Ecco c'è da capire una cosa che il bosco
non ha affatto bisogno di noi può andare
avanti libero e indisturbato anche se la
nostra specie Si estinguesse domattina
Siamo noi che abbiamo tantissimo bisogno
del Bosco ed è per questo motivo che il
disinteresse l'abbandono diffuso dei
Boschi genera enormi problemi perché ci
allontana dai servizi ecosistemici
problemi che possono essere vicini ma
anche molto lontani vicini come gli
incendi sempre più intensi e violenti
nel contesto della crisi climatica ho
molto lontani come la deforestazione che
non è gestione del bosco ma è
cancellazione del bosco che avviene in
paese appunto molto lontani da cui la
importiamo sotto forma di carne di pelle
di soia di legno illegale fedeli al
motto occhio non vede cuore non duole
per non toccare i nostri Boschi Allora
andiamo a distruggere quelli degli altri
Certo però che non è che allora possiamo
entrare nei nostri Boschi a raccogliere
tutto ciò che ci serve no i boschi vanno
gestiti bene bisogna pianificare la loro
gestione bisogna fare una selvicoltura
con la s maiuscola e c'è bisogno che i
boschi si rinnovino costantemente Perché
sì devono essere utili a noi oggi ma
devono rimanere presenti e funzionali
anche per le generazioni future
vedete quella che sto cercando di
raccontarvi questa sera è una storia un
po' difficile da narrare perché alla
fine è una storia di buon senso di
equilibrio e queste storie qui
normalmente non prendono le prime pagine
dei giornali ma io sono convinto che si
debba continuare a scriverle e
raccontarle insieme perché altrimenti
rischiamo di strappare quel legame così
antico che ci lega ad alberi e a boschi
e se si rompe quel legame forse prima
saltano i boschi Ma poi se saltano i
boschi Allora saltiamo anche noi
e quindi domattina quando farete
colazione su un bel tavolo di legno
magari ascoltando buona musica e poi
quando aprirete il vostro rubinetto per
lavarvi i denti Pensateci Ma pensate non
solo all'incredibile valore del bosco di
cui forse tanti di noi hanno già
percezione pensate anche al valore della
sua gestione a quegli uomini a quelle
donne che lavorano spesso nell'ombra in
luoghi molto lontani un po' sperduti e
che talvolta vengono accusati di essere
dei distruttori della natura perché di
mestiere anche tagliano gli alberi
accuse che arrivano Forse da persone che
vedono la nostra specie come qualcosa di
totalmente estraneo rispetto alla natura
ma noi siamo parte della natura Il bosco
è nelle nostre case è nelle nostre vite
con il bosco interagiamo ogni giorno
anche se non ce ne rendiamo conto ed è
per questo motivo che bisogna mantenere
viva questa relazione seguendo quel
sentiero magari un po' stretto però io
credo orribile della sostenibilità ecco
quando
ho pensato a questo Ted Ho immaginato a
una massima che mi viene sempre in mente
che io non sopporto fa molto più rumore
un albero solo che cade di un'intera
foresta che cresce Io stasera sto
provando ad alzare il volume di quei
boschi che se gestiti bene possono
crescere ma insieme a noi
e quindi
per concludere dato che stasera ho
chiesto di poter entrare nelle vostre
case ora vi dico usciamo fuori mettiamo
in luce ciò che è in controluce torniamo
nei boschi torniamo a camminare nei
boschi Torniamo a parlare con chi i
boschi li gestisce a confrontarci con le
comunità che più nei boschi vicini ai
boschi vivono generando servizi utili
anche a noi che viviamo in città
impariamo a conoscere i boschi in Italia
sono tantissimi sono il 40% della
superficie del nostro paese
e nell'ultimo secolo pensate sono
praticamente raddoppiati anche se Chissà
perché tutti pensano che siano diminuiti
imparate a conoscere i boschi scoprirete
che non sono solo una macchia verde
confusa è un po' sfocata Nel panorama e
che la loro gestione sostenibile è
qualcosa di veramente interessante a mio
parere meraviglioso Perché la ricerca
continua di un equilibrio possibile
Grazie